five
oh he had the part three okay okay the
pickup nice
it's so hard to do especially when it's
online i gotta you gotta give props to
this guy hear me though
equal health can he get to come back in
no you should just watch that foreign
converted
opportunity for erie to make a crazy
comeback here
oh no
you hate to see it
four
perry falls up the couple no he drops it
fabc gets another combo in all worth it
where are we going can't reach the wall
here too far
rain
beautiful call out he's super dead i
love you
three sides three
on the last hit
what timing on that spring kick their
back were knocking me enough to kill
backs the way back to one again too far
that time
oh what a side
opportunity to punish here rgn just one
hit away jules is gonna commute right
choice if he wants to close this one out
he does he does have meteorology
wastes the opportunity to close things
out maybe two
but coffee prince does stick with the
brian
oh my goodness
what
that was
very
low parry though mario is just looking
sharp unlockable set up
okay yo this is not looking good but he
still got the timing in one
oh my goodness
break it oh my god aka please looking
really good
the down four is done
somewhere even one of these days you
gotta block them
takes it
[Music]
[Music]
you